it's November first 2015 time for me to
shoot another monthly update video in
which I tell all of my viewers and
subscribers about what went on in the
last month and what we've got coming up
this month I always like to begin by
highlighting three big things the first
one I think is pretty evident if you
just look behind me and you see the
changed backdrop we have moved to
Milwaukee Wisconsin I'll tell you all
about that in the October portion two
things coming up in November that are
particularly cool both of which are
connected with stoicism as a
philosophical movement and as a way of
improving one's own life the first is
stoic week which I am participating in
here by hosting a stoic week event in
milwaukee wisconsin i'll tell you about
that in the november section but if
wherever you are in the world you should
enroll you should you should get
involved with the stoic week online
events that are going on if there's
anything happening near you in New York
or London or other places like that i
would i would definitely go to them a
third thing is i am going to be teaching
a free 4 week online class with the
global Center for Advanced Studies
specifically on epictetus discourses a
text that I've long had quite a strong
interest in and found very useful in my
own life again I'll talk about that in
the November section so let's talk about
the month of October the biggest thing
of course is we have moved we are now in
milwaukee wisconsin and this is our
hometown both my wife andy and i are
from this area originally in my family
the branch of the family that that i'm
from moved up to this area so there
weren't an awful lot of us most of my
family is in the Chicagoland area but
her family you know her immediate family
is from here we have lots of old
classmates and friends I've already got
to see a few of them great great fun to
catch up with people and it's an amazing
city
I mean they've done a lot with it since
we were here and it's so great to be
home I'm working partly out of the
apartment because I've got plenty of
space now as opposed to the place that
we were living in before we probably now
have I would say close to four times the
space that we were working with
previously and we've got a great kitchen
setup you know the bathrooms are all set
up the office not quite so much there's
about 90 boxes of books to be unloaded
you see those those Tim that lumber
behind me that's supposed to be a
bookshelf that's a bookshelf in potentia
that I'm going to have to create later
on today with you know basically just
screwing things together but I've got to
make quite a few more those towels our
library but it's this is really great
we've got plenty of room I've got a
place upstairs where I can I can shoot
videos and I've already started shooting
some for the half-hour Hagel I'm working
out of a collaborative office space
downtown actually the third ward if you
know where that is in Milwaukee called
the Hudson business lounge I think it's
called that because there's also a cafe
right next to called the Hudson so that
is the really big information a bit
really big event if you like it took
several days of pretty intense stuff to
get here I already shot a video about
that so I don't need to tell you those
stories again I will say this i am
extraordinarily happy to be here it was
good to be in New York it was a great
experience but there's nothing like
coming home so what else October saw the
American Catholic philosophical
association in which I gave two papers
both in Satellite sessions one was in
the International hdangel soul society
and I gave a paper there on 18 jul saw
Christian philosophy his model of it and
whether Kierkegaard's philosophical
fragments would fit into that you can
see the link below that if you're
interested in hearing the talk or
reading it you can you can get it
through that I also by invitation gave a
paper at the Gabrielle Marcel society
about Marcel and jean-paul sartre as
polemical interlocutors in the
existentialist movement and that was a
lot of fun as well the ACPA is a great
conference for me not just because you
know I do I am a Catholic and I also
work with in you might call it the
Catholic intellectual traditions notice
that I use the plural there but it's
also a great time for me to catch up
with a lot of old friends and colleagues
not all of them are Catholic by the way
and the ACPA is kind of a philosophical
umbrella organization not only do they
have all their own sessions but they
have all these societies as well like
the Gabrielle Marcel society or the
Institute for st. Anselm studies meets
there or the International Society for
McIntyre an inquiry all of which I you
know try to attend so all of that was a
lot of fun and that would happen just
days before he actually moved out here
so you can tell how compressed
everything out was while we were setting
things up here in Milwaukee I did manage
to hold a public half-hour Hagel Q&A
session by google hangout had some great
conversations with some of the people
who have been backers of the project and
some people who are just interested in
in hegel and aren't already connected
with the half-hour Hagel project but
wanted to know more about it so that was
the main events I didn't get so much
blogging done as i would have liked so I
always you know feel a little bit bad
about that but maybe during stoic week
I'm going to work out not feeling so bad
about things I'm still teaching online
classes I did that throughout the entire
move teaching for marist and
you know for for the g KS getting online
classes ready for the g KS and for a
player no i did some consulting stuff as
well mostly having to do with talking
with with other people who are working
in online institutions or are trying to
do entrepreneurial stuff on their own
and helping them sort through some of
their their ideas and and some of the
problems and giving them a sounding
board now I did shoot some videos as
well I released six half hour Hagel
videos we finished up with the
master-slave dialectic and we are now in
the section stoicism skepticism and the
unhappy consciousness right in time for
stoic week so that turns out really
really convenient I still am releasing
Plato core concept symposium videos from
the symposium class that I I led back in
August so you can tell how how backed up
i am with with videos i have a few of
those yet to release but i managed to
get quite a few of those out this month
i also created a video about the move
and i did a video interview not in my
own channel but in a channel called
groundwork for the metaphysics of mig
tau with marcus who wanted to tap my
expertise as a historian of philosophy
as somebody working in ethics and as a
philosophical counselor to talk about
what what day and that movement called
the the red pill rage and so it was it
was quite an interesting interview i'll
put a link to it and if you're
interested in that sort of thing you can
go and check it out so that's October
what have we got coming up in November
well this is a really cool month from a
philosophical perspective because of
mainly because of work other people have
done which I'm for which I'm very
grateful the people over at the
University of Exeter and the modern
stoicism blog
have a class called stoic week also
called stoicism today they they do a
one-week class every year they've done
this for several years this year they're
concentrating on Marcus Aurelius as
meditations and it's it's um you know
it's not going into too much detail
about you know the thinker or the
movement or anything like that it's more
about learning how to apply stoicism in
one's own life and so they create a
handbook they create a bunch of sound
files that you can use for listening at
the beginning of the day at the end of
the day there's a lot of structured
exercises forums for people to do so I'm
doing that class again this year I found
it great last year and I'm really happy
to be to be connected with it I'm doing
my own stoic week event here in
Milwaukee which they've been kind enough
to post on on their blog that is going
to be November fifth 7 p.m. at the
Hudson business lounge downtown you can
find the event on Google+ or on Facebook
i'll link to it here that's a free event
so if you have any interest if you're in
the area come on show up and we'll talk
about stoicism and how it can improve
one's one's life which is really what
what stoicism is one of its main focuses
is I also have one other event going on
this month the November half-hour Hagel
Q&A session which I'll be holding by
Google hangout that is the last
wednesday of the month and i'll post
information about that as well another
big thing I've got going on like I
mentioned earlier is I'm going to be
offering a class which is already open
for enrollment by the way i'll put the
link below on epictetus discourses now
epictetus most people know him for the
enchiridion or the hand
and that's sort of a best hits list or
almost the best hits medley if you want
to call it that from his much larger
discourses that were written down by one
of his his close friends and pupils
Aryan so the discourses is epictetus is
full teaching at least what we've got of
it and I'm going to be teaching this
four-week class in the class I'll
actually post a video about that a
little bit later on this month but just
to tell you about it I always provide
links to videos handouts lesson sections
forums in which people can participate
there won't be any homework assignments
because you know I don't have to do any
grading if it's a free class because it
you know I'm already putting work into
it but it's going to be a lot of fun I
think a lot of great learning will take
place and I'm very excited to teach it
so what else we've got videos coming up
this month I'll be shooting a sequence
of seven videos including one later on
today one each day of stoic week which
began today officially you know over in
England there you know six hours ahead
of us here so they got the drop on us
today I'm going to be shooting one video
that's sort of an introduction of what's
going on with stoic week and then I'm
going to be doing videos primarily on
Cicero's discussions of Stoicism in
works like on duties and on the end and
the tusculum disputations and perhaps
even on the nature of the gods if I if I
get around to it I'm also going to
videotape the or video record will tape
anything these dates right midi to
record the stoic week event that'll be
one of the stoa stoicism week videos and
I'll have a later hang out to talk about
that with anybody who couldn't be here
in Milwaukee but would like to talk
about the themes in that that'll be
later on this month more play-doh core
concept videos I've still got a few of
those to release
I'm going to also be releasing ahead of
time I hope hope some Epictetus core
concept videos because I'm going to be
creating a lot more of those for the
Epictetus discourses class and I'm
hoping but not promising that I will be
able to shoot the long-promised current
events video and get going with those
and i think this this month i think it
makes sense to focus on the ongoing
refugee crisis over in the Middle East
and in Europe and to talk about that so
I'm going to be doing if i can get to it
and that's you know i'm going to try to
get to it i'm hoping to do a lot more
blogging this month in in all of my
blogs are exes do you know NTK virtue
ethics digest Sandler's existentialism
updates half hour Hagel blog and of
course heavy metal philosopher I've got
some consulting things already lined up
as a matter of fact I had I had some
earlier today that I had to hit you know
attend to that's why I'm shooting the
video a little bit later but I have some
pretty big but sort of at this point up
in the air things lined up that I have
to work on and work through you know I'm
going to be sending out queries as far
as speaking gigs now that I'm in a new
territory I have to sort of rebuild
everything so I'm going to be sending
things out the library seeing if
somebody wants to do one of those
year-long series like we did in Kingston
the last two years so one last thing
that I'll say to wrap this up if you're
at a if you're involved with a school or
a library a church a business
organization and you're interested in
bringing me in to do a talk send me an
email at Greg at reason I oh and I'll
certainly you know work it through with
you talk about whether it's feasible
what you're interested in hearing about
you know who your audience is we're
really looking to
build a lot of speaking long-term
relationships out here so if you're
interested in that sort of thing send me
an email otherwise a lot of cool stuff
happening this month and if you can make
it to any of the events including the
online events do so if not you know
there'll be the videos for several of
them and I hope all of you have a great
month